[Music]
my name is vince cerf i'm vice president
of google
and google's chief internet evangelist
[Music]
about 50 years ago my colleague robert
khan and i and a number of other people
started to work on the problem of
getting computers to talk to each other
and that meant designing and building
networks
we developed something called arpanet
interconnect
each of the computers to each other to
form a fully connected network
on the basis of the success of the
arpanet we developed a multiple network
system to connect computers
all over the world called the internet
the most interesting thing about the
internet today is that it covers the
entire globe
about half of the world's population is
online but some of us who have been
working on deep space communication
asked the question what would it take to
build
a network that would span the entire
solar system
in order to support manned and robotic
space exploration
many people ask us why would you build
an interplanetary internet
are you thinking that aliens will show
up and they need the network to
communicate with you
well no but the honest truth is humans
are leaving the planet we've been
sending spacecraft out to many of the
planets and asteroids and other parts of
our
immediate solar system we've already
been to the moon we're going back to the
moon in 2024 and in 2030 or thereabouts
we will
make our first human visit to planet
mars in order to
get the data back and in order to tell
the spacecraft what to do we have to
[Music]
communicate
[Music]
we looked at the internet and we thought
we could use it that way and we
discovered very quickly the speed of
light is too slow
we had to develop a new set of protocols
that deal with variable
delay and disruption because of
planetary rotation
and celestial motion so the
interplanetary internet
has harder problems to solve than the
terrestrial one does
but it used very similar kinds of
techniques it uses radio
it does not use optical fiber we're not
going to string an optical fiber between
planet earth and the moon or mars or
anything else so we have to use radio
or we may actually use lasers to give us
higher speed
as you know if you're using the internet
today rich connectivity
creates resilience and that is what we
are after with the interplanetary system
a resilient
and interplanetary scale communication
system
to support manned and robotic space
exploration
today we have an interplanetary system
starting to operate
on the international space station on
planet earth
and on planet mars
you